In Saudi Arabia, the royal family announces a new Islamic military alliance...
...made up of 34 countries to fight terrorism.
In Switzerland, the United Nations-sponsored peace talks...
...aimed at finding a settlement to the conflict in Yemen open in Geneva.
In Russia, Secretary of State John Kerry tells Russian President Vladimir Putin in Moscow...
...that Russia and the United States can work together...
...to make progress in ending the war in Syria.
In the US, all public schools across Los Angeles, California...
...were closed Tuesday due to a "credible threat."
And finally from the Vatican,...
...Pope Francis calls on governments to review their laws on migration...
...in order to welcome refugees and help them integrate into society.